toronto capitale économique du canada
une ville où les inégalités sont
criantes livre dans la ville reine a
toujours été dispendieux mais la crise
est flat sioniste marginalise de plus en
plus de torontois
jay 44 ans vit les effets de cette crise
chaque semaine elle fait deux heures
d'autobus pour aller à la banque
alimentaire
sur place elle trouve des produits frais
et des denrées non périssables
pas assez pour une épicerie complète
mais suffisamment pour lui permettre de
tenir quelques jours
chaque cinq comptes explique la
torontoise c'est en 2018 qu'elle s'est
rendue dans une banque alimentaire pour
la première fois jay avait ensuite
réussi à stabiliser sa situation
financière de clientes elle était même
devenue bénévole pour daily bread mais
avec l'inflation c'est le retour à la
case départ
[Musique]
le quai de jay est loin d'être isolé
alors que de plus en plus de torontois
ont besoin d'aidé alimentaire
daily bread est aux premières loges de
cette explosion de la demande c'est une
des plus grandes banques alimentaires de
toronto avec près de 200 points de
service aux quatre coins de la ville
chaque jour des milliers de kilogrammes
de nourriture transitent par l'entrepôt
le rythme est soutenu la machine bien
huilée de quoi donner le tournis
nous avons dû tripler la quantité de
nourriture très rapidement explique le
pdg de daily bread le nombre de clients
mensuelle de la banque alimentaire est
passé de 65 mille en 2020 à 170 mille
aujourd'hui parmi ces nouveaux clients
beaucoup de familles et de personnes qui
travaillent à temps plein mais qui
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
et nageurs
face à cet afflux de clients daily bread
doit mettre les bouchées doubles la
banque alimentaire compte sur des dons
privés et sur l'aide de bénévoles comme
en chine ce tueur qui donne un coup de
main en cuisine d'une fois par semaine
cross c'est devenu plus important à
cause du coût de la vie explique votre
et pire qu'ils constatent l'impact de
l'inflation sur son propre portefeuille
mais même avec l'aide de bénévoles
dévoués difficile de répondre à la
demande surtout que daily bread est
aussi victime de l'inflation
leur budget pour acheter de la
nourriture est passé de 1 million et
demi de dollars en 2020 à 13 millions de
dollars cette année
quand va-t-on atteindre notre point de
rupture s'inquiète d'ailleurs d'assen la
chercheuse souligne que les banques
alimentaires ne peuvent pas à elles
seules mettre fin à l'insécurité
alimentaire
devant l'absence de solution
structurelle des milliers de torontois
comme jay continuent d'être confrontés à
des choix difficiles
entre jeunes
et neufs
dans l'autobus sur le chemin du retour
avec son panier plein de nourriture j'ai
plutôt fait souffler grâce au petit
répit offerts par la banque alimentaire
une bouée de sauvetage alors que le
quotidien devient de plus en plus
difficile et si la semaine et radio
canada toronto